we go it was quite the sight on a
Saturday afternoon over South Carolina
[Music]
a spectacle but a moment of potential
huge consequence too that's my Air Force
right there buddy
at 2 39 in the afternoon a single
air-to-air missile fired from one of two
American F-22 fighter jets
a direct hit on the white dot which has
caused days of intrigue Amusement but
diplomatic drama too
from an altitude of 58 000 feet the jet
fired up hitting the balloon which was
between 60 and 65 000 feet
[Music]
it begins to deflate immediately
we're told it fell to the ocean from
where debris so precious to both sides
will now be collected by the Americans
and analyzed
President Biden had authorized the hit
on Wednesday but the military waited
until the balloon was above water
they decided without doing damage to
anyone on on the ground they decided
that the best time to do that was it got
over water outside within our within 12
mile limit
I successfully took it down and I want
to complement our aviators who did it
and we'll have more to report on this a
little later
here at the Pentagon military commanders
had given the president options it was a
complex military operation but with a
political balance too pressure to take
the balloon down versus the geopolitical
consequences the focus here now will be
China's response the balloon was first
spotted publicly over Billings Montana
where America's intercontinental
ballistic missile silos are located
the helium-filled balloon was large the
latest report suggesting the payload
alone measured 35 meters in length it
was all part of a sophisticated spy
balloon the Americans say
I think the best explanation is probably
that they were trying to test the limits
and provoke the chances the weather
balloon are probably below one percent
the multi-agency operation Coast Guard
Navy and FBI has now been tasked with
combing a seven mile area the water is
just over 40 feet deep we're told that
will make the recovery easier China's
reaction to all this as yet unknown